Inside your skull is about one and a half
kilos of meat that somehow manages to keep
you breathing, help you remember where your
wallet is and remind you which is the best
hole to put your lunch in…err… not that
one.
And you know what, maths tests aside, it normally
does a pretty decent job of stuff.
But when you are dealing with something so
unbelievably complicated, among the billions
of humans all over the planet, you’re occasionally
going to have some pretty unusual brain anomalies.
There’s the obvious ones like amnesia and
dyslexia but today we’re looking at naughty
neurons, peculiar pathways and confusing consciousness;
we’re looking at 6 bizarre brain disorders.
Riley Day sounds like an awful 90s pop star
but it’s actually a genetic condition, officially
named Familial dysautonomia, which has the
notable effect of making people unable to
feel pain.
But if you’re wondering “okay, so where
is this race of super people?”
Well it also causes poor growth, unstable
blood pressure, violent vomiting, pneumonia
and problems with speech and movement.
So, whilst I’m sure they’d love to help
save you from a burning building, they kind
of have their own issues to deal with.
It’s also very unique to one group of people.
The only ever cases of Riley-Day syndrome
have been found in Ashkenazi Jews.
Jewish people are, for the most part, split
into 3 ethnic groups; Ashkenazi, Sephardic
and Mizrahi.
Ashkenazi is the biggest group, originally
from Eastern Europe, containing about 11 million
people, half of which live in the US.
To really rub it in, sufferers also don’t
produce tears.
There’s also an opposite condition; Hyperalgesia,
which is a hyper-sensitivity to pain.
This one’s not genetic though, it can be
caused by long-term opioid use, like with
heroin addiction.
Next we have Alice in Wonderland Syndrome.
What do you think this is?
Do you go chasing rabbits?
Do you see smiling cats wherever you go?
No, in this wonderland, you lose control of
your perception of size and things seem all
out of proportion like you’re Alice, eating
the cake and drinking from the bottle, growing
and shrinking.
The medical terms are micropsia and macropsia;
that’s seeing things as small and seeing
them as big.
Or you can get pelopsia and teleopsia, where
objects seem nearer or further away.
Unsurprisingly, this can happen through taking
hallucinogenic drugs but it also affects those
with severe migraines and brain tumors.
Many children experience a form of it at some
point but it disappears in teenage years.
It’s also one of the symptoms of the Epstein–Barr
virus, which is a type of herpes.
Interestingly, Lewis Carrol was known to suffer
from migraines so perhaps this was his inspiration
for the distorted world down the rabbit hole.
I don’t want to know how he got the idea
of an extremely high caterpillar though.
The Cheshire Cat once said “If you do not
know where you want to go, it doesn’t matter
which path you take” and this leads us to
our next condition; aboulomania.
This is what we call pathological indecisiveness.
A lot of people say they’re bad at making
decisions and might spend ten minutes gnawing
at their finger nails as their eyes jump from
chocolate cake to cheesecake… obviously
chocolate cake, you idiot … but this is
much worse than that.
Decision making involves various parts of
the brain and varies depending on the type
of choice, for example it’s a different
process for a free choice such as “what’s
your favourite sandwich?”
compared to a closed choice such as “beer
or cider”.
With Aboulomania, the sufferers massively
over-analyze the options, always thinking
of the worst outcomes and so manage to talk
themselves out of ever doing anything, effectively
becoming socially paralyzed.
Now let’s talk some sense.
There’s a lot of misunderstanding about
the senses, for example the idea that there
are only 5 of them.
What about the sense of balance? of pain?
and proprioception?
which is an understanding of the relative
positions of your body parts.
Synesthesia is a condition where perceptions
that are normally separate become mixed, such
as seeing numbers as colours or tasting words.
There are many different forms but the number-colour
thing is the most common, affecting yellow
out of purple people with the condition.
Some of the rarer forms of the condition include
seeing time as shapes and feeling other people’s
sensations, like if you saw someone scratching
their leg, you would immediately feel that
same scratching on your own thigh, it’s
like a hyper form of empathy.
The list of famous synesthetes, as they’re
called, includes Pharrell Williams, Tesla
and Kandinsky
Prosopagnosia is an impairment of your facial-recognition
ability, controlled by the fusiform gyrus
in your frontal lobe.
It can even result in not being able to recognize
your own face, which means you can play Where’s
Wally with your own family album.
A common issue that most of us have is a difficulty
telling apart people of different races.
And it seems that it’s not that we can’t
tell the difference, it’s just that we don’t.
Psychologist Daniel Levin puts it like this;
“When a white person looks at another white
person's nose, they're likely to think to
themselves, 'That's John's nose.'
When they look at a black person's nose, they're
likely to think, 'That's a black nose.'"
For your own race you look in a holistic way,
getting an overall impression of it, whereas
with other races you just bounce around the
features, like you’ve not seen a face before
and are trying to understand it.
Simply because your brain is less use to seeing
faces of other races than of your own.
Obviously this improves dramatically if you
live in a multi-cultural area.
But for those with prosopagnosia, there’s
no real way to improve they’re facial recognitions
abilities, so they have to rely on remembering
people’s dress sense or body language in
order to distinguish them.
Not recognizing your own face is one thing
but what about not knowing who is in charge
of your hand?
Alien Hand Syndrome was first documented in
Germany in 1908 and has since been most commonly
associated with people who’ve had the two
hemispheres of their brain surgically separated,
often as a cure for epilepsy.
But it can also occur after various brain
conditions like Alzheimer’s, tumors and
so on.
With Alien Hand Syndrome, one hand moves purposefully,
seemingly of its own will and the owner of
the hand can do nothing to stop it no matter
how hard they try.
If there are any bosses watching who have
had a sexual harassment allegation made against
them, don’t try to use Alien Hand Syndrome
as an excuse, you are just a creep and you
deserve to be fired.
The brain is unbelievably complicated and
we never know what unusual brain syndrome
will manifest itself, out of the blue.
So, if you’re worried that you’ll never
stop smoking weed in your bedroom, playing
Call of Duty and skipping on the housework,
maybe just keep sticking it out until the
world finally recognizes your “Faulty-Motivational-Syndrome”
and you might get the sympathy you richly
deserve.